when you meet joe biden
bring three masks one for your face and
two for his hands
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
keep clapping clap till you die
all right knock it off her name's nicole
and she's quite a troll
i think if someone were to parachute
down here um
and wonder what the most sort of
destructive force on our planet is and
they landed
in this country they might look at the
republicans
her voice is like butter so you got that
yeah the worst thing on the planet ain't
terrorists cancer
not even global warming for once it's
republicans
and all this time the dems told us it
was russia
keep going nicole when is someone in the
republican party going to rise up
against those in the republican party
whose speech and language and their
selection of debates are still killing
people
yes once again it's those evil
republicans
killing people those damn pro-lifers
but it's always the same isn't it the
republicans want you to die
except isn't she a republican nicole is
so two-faced
she better be double masking and i seem
to remember a lot of people dying in
wars under her watch
she should turn herself into the u.n for
crimes against humanity
and human eardrums but don't be foolish
enough to think
wallace is being original she just stole
her screed
from a very old playbook we are
handing over our kurdish allies to
slaughter
and that blood is going to be on donald
trump's hands these republicans in the
senate
seem to have an endless tolerance
for other people's sadness the
republicans are responsible they all
will have blood on their hands
i believe they have blood on their hands
and no one
should forget that so here's the
divisive narrative the media is
currently pounding out
that it's republicans who hate vaccines
but in order to believe this lie you
must pretend that
operation warp speed which happened
under a republican
never existed yes it disappeared just
like a conservative social media page
and you also have to deny that states
governed by republicans did way better
in vaccine rollout preventing covert
death and reducing unemployment
and you'd have to forget it was kamala
harris who said she wouldn't trust any
vaccine put forth by donald trump
as if as if he were mixing up doses at a
port-a-potty in a landfill
fact states with republican governors
have lower death rates
beating the blue states who stricter
lockdowns led to their higher
unemployment
according to the las vegas review
journal if blue states had the same
jobless
rate as red states 900 000 more people
would be employed
but as much as i can easily uh dismantle
nicole's
what's the point if you
the viewer would just step outside of
the left versus right dem versus
republican
rich versus poor crap you can see how
much of this unsettling reality is
manufactured
by social media companies media giants
and politicians
as long as we fight amongst ourselves
they keep their power
and get rich off our warring factions by
now jeff zucker should have a yacht
called the divide and conquer
so where's the president wasn't joe's
whole
soul into healing this nation
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause so what happened
nothing because he lied remember this is
the same guy who used the find people
hoax to win an election
he also pushed the drinking bleach lie
to bran trump and his supporters as
deadly neanderthals
you know those crazy cavemen who want to
earn a living and drive around bedrock
without a vaccine passport
so what did our healer say yesterday
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and other states to
smarten up stop it
stop it
was that healing and referring to voter
id laws as jim crow
is he aware that over 70 of blacks favor
photo ids for voting
biden is to healing what a surgeon's
dirty scalpel is to a patient
which is the point unification isn't the
goal
conflict is and once you see this
framework it shows up everywhere
i mean take a look at what's on cnn
right now
grandma's
maybe the bear does have a point there
the bear is a racist
he is a racist all right so the point of
this show
is to pull you and i out of these
destructive us versus them narratives
by trying to show you how the media
creates false stories
to keep us engaged and angry i don't
hate dems
i don't hate liberals i hate the media
for wanting
us to hate each other that's their game
it's a terrible one and
the way you win is by being the first
and loudest without facts or context
it's not good or healthy but you know
what is watching this show
and leaving this prison of two ideas
behind
the left right thing is deader than a
bill submitted to congress by aoc
it's now you versus the manipulating
monolith called the media
the good news now that you can see their
game you can't unsee it and that means
you and i
can kick their asses together
let's welcome tonight's death he can't
be
tamed and neither can't his hair
washington times
opinion editor fox news contributor
charlie hurt
[Applause]
she has a camera in one hand and the
truth in the other director producer of
the documentary the plot against the
president
filmmaker amanda milius
she's like a syringe sharp skinny and
full of medication
hosted sincerely counter fox nation cat
tip
and he's cooler than a penguin spot
comedian joe mackey
all right amanda i have i every time i
have this
hope that the left right thing is
collapsing right before our eyes
do you feel that way why do you have
that hope it's so much worse than it's
ever been before
well maybe it could be that i'm
delusional i mean
maybe but uh i mean with people like
wallace it's uh it's just getting worse
it's really awful i love that she's um
basically like the whitest of white
ladies who's like
digging up this uh you know controversy
like throwing everything uh and the
kitchen sink at republicans i mean it's
just unbelievable i mean this is why
that this is
this is why the country is so divided
it's unbelievable see i don't
i i still disagree charlie because she's
now part of the media
and the media cannot make money off
agreement yeah right and and i'm i'm
saying that i am guilty
of i'm trying to change that uh of
choosing sides i try to hate everybody
including you charlie you're pretty good
at that
yes and i'm kind of mad that you cut
your hair but that's a different story
where do you feel uh how do you feel
about the republicans being the most
destructive force on the planet
literally you have an administration
that has single-handedly
created a crisis at the border yes where
you have women are being
raped uh children are being smuggled
across the border
you have people being sold into literal
slavery
in 2021 and then that's just at the
border
uh you know you have these people that
have launched a war on cops
people have died right because of the
democrats war
on the police you have mayhem you have
people that have been murdered
and you have all of these things and you
have and the only way
that the democrats um
you know haven't been run out of town on
a rail is because they have the media
behind them
peddling all of these lies and telling
these ridiculous
claims about evil republicans and evil
trump the one thing i i might add about
uh
i love the clip from biden it may be
possible
i didn't think that it was possible any
president could be funnier than donald
trump yeah
i'm now starting to think maybe joe
biden is actually funnier than donald
trump even if he doesn't mean to be
yeah he's kind of like but the fact that
he's transformed into like a vessel for
wokeness
yeah it's like finding out mr magoo is
into body modification
no he he is he is the white privileged
presidency
the only reason he's there is because he
was a non-threatening old white guy
back in 2008 who could never get
anywhere near the white house and obama
needed him
yes it's like cat i've said this before
it's like the left
treats joe the way they they treat a
befuddled grandfather they just
put him in the backseat of the car take
him to the atm and just take all of his
money
they do that they get they do it to the
limits you want to go get ice cream
yeah but you're going to go to the atm
first and we're going to take out the
maximum which is 500
yeah and look i just get sick of the
people say
republicans are the worst i'd say the
same thing if anyone say democrats are
the most harmful force right
because all you're doing when you
ostracize and demonize half the country
is you're just propping yourself up on
this like moral superiority fluffy
pillow
so that you get to be above everyone
else without having to you know
get up off your ass and do anything at
all
and it's harmful because that's can
at worst lead to people getting
radicalized
and it certainly doesn't make people who
might disagree with you want to open up
their minds to new ideas
and nothing gets done yes i like the
fact that nothing gets done
except that you know what i this whole
atlanta story joe
it's completely generated by a false
narrative created by the media that
somehow this voter id
law was racist meanwhile they still have
the masters
right yeah it's called the masters
[Laughter]
if master bedrooms are racist the
masters are racist
masturbation is racist master chef
is racist what is masturbation no i
don't know is your dad watching oh
your dad's in the audience very good joe
i am dying to find out what's in your
brain
i was very inspired by your monologue
that's why i'm not going to use
any ridiculous hyperbole to criticize
nicole wallace's scenario because
if if if aliens landed on the planet
republicans
couldn't be the most destructive force
on the planet
it would be the aliens according to
every movie i've ever watched
good luck selling that screenplay where
aliens come to
the to earth and nicole
haley is the person everyone's running
for
but this could be a movie because if the
aliens come
and you we're all republicans are
anti-immigration
they come the only savior for the planet
will be the republicans they have to
face off
and they like have arguments about ideas
yes
i think this is actually a great idea
for a movie the aliens come and they
want to raise taxes
oh all right that's enough